I've some questions about that Quran as
safe to comment on surah number four
yeah why is it said that men boys should
get twice more heritage than women then
go for that since there are two in surah
2 as well it must mean so first and okay
so the point is it doesn't say half by
the way okay
because if you calculate the proportions
if you calculate the proportion the man
is responsible for the living of the
ladies of the house yes well there is
some mother when it's a wife or a
daughter or sister so if a man inherits
from the father he must yield from his
shear his mother sister wife and
daughters okay
so he uses a shared on the other hand
whatever women inherit from the deceased
the wife she keeps her share yes the
mother keeps our share the daughters
keep the share they do not have to spend
a penny from they share it is the
responsibility of the men so hence the
wisdom of an extra share for the men so
that they can actually sustain the
family they can continue to sustain the
family because it's their responsibility
to provide for the family
in Islamic reciting
did you know that in surah nisa it
breaks it down here
so for example there are the people who
get 50% again is the beauty we can have
it 50% is the husband if the husband is
not there it's the daughter the
granddaughter the horse is in the patent
system that means for females get more
than one man in a specific instance but
it s better 66.7% you get sick you get
2/3 yeah ok if the Sun let's suppose if
I have a dual-channel son imagine have
three daughters and one son if my if my
son taught with fast passes away you
know you get see the situation my Brutus
is my granddaughter's the processes in
the future no sisters they gets more
than a man but which are many men listen
to this carefully
in search of specific instances here
Ellie a woman a woman gets more than 13
male family members 1330 male family
knows for example
a woman in certain instances gets more
than the grand grandson the father the
grandfather the full bother the paternal
rather the maternal over the nephew of
the fool brother the nephew of the
Paterno brother the full uncle paternal
the heart uncle paternal cousin of the
cool uncle the cousin of the hospital
and the husband it's all according to
the caronian calculation so if there is
no son
a woman gets more than 13 different male
family members yeah that's that's
interesting
[Music]